Hi I'm Julie Stanford and my superpower is
designing technologies and experiences that people
love. I wear two hats. Half my time I'm at the
Stanford computer science department where I teach
learners like you how to do research and design
for technological change. The other half of my
time, I'm at Slice Bread a consulting agency I
founded where I practice what I preach. Through my
consulting work I've witnessed many well-intended
digital transformation projects with with low
adoption, lots of headaches along the way. Here's
what I've learned from these failed projects. Even
though the term digital transformation sounds
like it's about technology, turns out the secret
to success is to shift your focus to the people at
the center. If you want to make sure that the new
technologies you introduce have long-term impact,
you need to start with a human-centered approach.
We'll begin this course by taking a deep dive
into interview techniques that you can employ to
uncover the true root causes of problems. Then
we'll learn how to squeeze as much insight as
we can from that data. And finally we'll cover a
systematic process for running rapid experiments
to validate your ideas and minimize risk at every
step. Along the way we'll analyze case studies,
and you'll work through project-based exercises
that will help you apply what you've learned.
What are some of the things you do at the
beginning. Business leader Jonathan Alloy
will provide additional industry insights on how
to plan, test, and launch an effective digital
transformation What you really have to do is
step outside of your own preconceived biases
and truly listen. Be willing to follow up and
dig and probe and ask why. My goal is to help
you up-level your career by teaching you how
to use human centered tools to confidently run
a successful digital transformation project. So
join us from wherever you are at Stanford Online.